so on the roll
to me that's clearly a foul he's jumping
point a to point b
and gets him with the body but
i think the clippers are far too
frustrated right now with officiating
versus
being more accountable for better play
shot clock winding down
paul george goes inside blocked by
porzingis but a whistle and a foul
and a technical foul has been handed out
jim hardaway signaling for a challenge
[Applause]
looks like a good block
[Applause]
do they take the technical point off too
no because if it's a terrible call
and it gets rid of overturned i know you
voice what causes this
why would you give them i mean they're
not gonna challenge
although i just think especially in the
playoff game
and we saw it earlier you know immediate
reaction you pump you
just as long as it's not a continuing
display and here's my only problem i'll
point
if you're gonna call that then be
consistent
then call it like that all the time oh i
agree i think either one of them should
have
now carla was was gonna challenge it but
it's too late
because they shot the technical free
throw already
i think it has to be within 30 seconds
mark ayotte one of the officials
kane fitzgerald eric lewis the other
i'd run the same play posing is set to
screen
[Applause]
carrying violation some extra words
after the play
morris and doncic porzingis getting in
the way and there's some shoves patrick
beverly getting involved
[Applause]
and quickly coaches come out on the
floor to get their players
out of the scrum
beverly now now now playing the role of
peacemaker taking morris
away from it morris and doncic joying at
each other
and the is officials to go take a look
please general review for altercation
so that's what donchez took exception to
after the whistle morris grabbing him
and then they start having some words
just some shoves nothing really
officials did a good job getting in the
middle
[Music]
there's got to be a technical though by
who
morris i'm not talking about this i'm
talking about the shovel porzingis after
that
i don't want anybody toss is not serious
but you want to control this game but
sometimes they'll give it because
porzingis became the third man in
then they have some smiles so then
you're saying at least a double
technical mic
is that what i understand you saying i
think that's more likely what we'll see
this guy should be about
they shouldn't on reviews they should go
straight to mike
but it's so good to see i mean the rules
being applied where
the players use wisdom the guys on the
bench nobody ran on the court
and participated it's the right thing it
can truly cost you not just monetarily
but playoff game here's kane fitzgerald
double technical fouls porzingis and
morris that's porzingis second
he's been ejected wow
forgot that he got one remember because
he punched that air so porzingis has
been
out of the game it's an automatic
ejection you know and he had two weak
technical fouls
i i hate ejections in the in the
playoffs like that i just think it's
the second one automatic and again
the reason he got it is because the
situation was between
doncic morris and he came in as a third
party and that's why he was part of it
and then morris with the shove
[Applause]
it used to be
that officiating had more license
for common sense and to me that is
nothing
that is nothing you should you're not
ejected for that
i i agree that's why i said
that's nonsense stuff that's why i said
technical with mars
for the shelf other than that i didn't
see anything else
hey we'll start we'll do uh we'll do
three or four here in the room and then
we'll go to zoom if that's cool
yep go ahead okay yeah we'll start with
brad and anybody in the room can raise
their hands did you think your objection
would want
you again so did you think your
objection was warranted does that mean
uh do you think you deserve to get the
second technical foul
no of course not of course not um but
i understand we we got into it a little
bit and uh
i saw him getting into luca's face and i
didn't like that that's why i reacted
and um
yeah that's a that's a smart smart thing
to do from their part
and i just got to be smarter and control
my emotions next time especially on the
first one i understand the second one
but the first one um even though i felt
like it was a clean
block they're probably gonna call that
tech for throwing a hand every time so
i just got to be smart and not let my
emotions get the better of me
yeah mark medina usa today did the
officials explain
why the second technical i was
i was already out uh but you know
they they probably they probably called
but
you know they looked at the replay and
then they did what they were supposed to
um
of course it's unfortunate and
in a different direction maybe but it is
what it is now i can't go back and
change it
and it's weird because i went through
all kinds of
scenarios that will happen in the game
you know how they were going to play us
and and
things i shouldn't do or you know or how
i should react
but this this was that one scenario i
didn't really think through that i might
get a tank and then don't get the second
thing you know so
it's a weird situation but i can
guarantee this this won't happen to me
again
taylor yeah so going off that you know
when it comes to playoff time
every single thing counts right and if
you aren't in the game people are
thinking about okay maybe the outcome
was different if christopher's on the
game
how do you get over that thinking about
maybe what you have since did
yeah yeah there's there's really not
much to do there you know you
you can think about the possibilities
but
but it is what it is at this point you
know we're already passed this game and
we're going to look at the mistakes
we've made and things we can do better
for for the second game and
our belief is still strong that we can
we can meet these guys you know
and um and that's it if we didn't have
that
belief we shouldn't be here anyway you
know so that's our mindset going into
the second game
when you described the second technical
you said they got in local space and
that was smart of that
way without
especially me i should have been smarter
i already had the technical which
i kind of didn't really have in my mind
um
i hadn't been in that situation really
you know and and and i was
smart of him to kind of grab luke and
get into his face and get a reaction out
of me
and uh yeah they got what they were
looking for basically is it